[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we make way for ian rappaport
nfl network insider you can follow him
on twitter at
rap sheet and you can see ian on nfl
networks nfl game day morning saturday
and sunday
at 9 00 a.m eastern uh ian thanks for
joining us where are you philosophically
on the eagles situation
i wasn't that offended i mean i was
watching like everyone else just kind of
i mean there was so much coaching stuff
going on gays got fired during the game
but i was
i was watching and all my friends a lot
of giants fans friends from home
from high school were all pissed and
everybody was freaking out and i
i couldn't find the anger and annoyance
i mean the steelers left all their
starters home
the bills played a bunch of backups they
just
i mean the fact that nate sudfield was
bad
isn't it i mean it's the eagle's fault
because he was on their roster but it's
not
totally their fault i mean i don't i
couldn't find the anger
i don't know i just i couldn't find it
yeah i understand that the giants want
to see
you know a fully equipped eagles
team and they want to go out there and
win and put your best you know effort
forward but ian we're going to run into
even more of these games when they add
week 17 more meaningless games where
more teams will be resting starters
so the nfl can't you know south
palantonio yesterday said you know the
nfl should investigate the eagles i
don't know how you investigate that
right i i it's i mean yeah hey did you
try to win
i mean right i mean so doug peterson
says yeah we tried to win it's like
well yeah but you also tried to evaluate
for next year
whatever you were trying to find out on
nate sudfeld you probably found out
i would also say this i loved what joe
judge said
too like his the eagles did what was
best for their team
they evaluated players they got a better
draft pick
which i don't think they were trying to
do but i'm just saying they played a lot
of
not good players and that's what
happened uh they did what's best for
them and i think joe judge's message is
something that's going to resonate with
giants fans
and i know it has already resonated with
giants players
they both did what's best for them and i
am really okay with that
yeah i hope joe judge doesn't go 12-4
and rest his starters
uh next year you know just just want to
let joe know
if you plan on being around this game a
long time chances are it's going to come
back and bite you there but
um the openings that we have right now
the best opening in your opinion is
where
everyone says the jaguars right because
you got the number one pick and you got
all the money and you got actually
multiple
uh draft picks and you got a patient
owner who's lived through
several years of doug maron i would say
the jagras is a very very good opening
i kind of feel like the chargers is the
best though because
like the jaguars are going to draft a
quarterback presumably turbo arms but
we'll see
especially if it's urban meyer we'll see
i think
trevor lawrence is a great prospect and
i think a lot of people think he's the
best prospect we've seen in
quite a while we've not seen him on an
nfl field i have seen justin herbert on
an nfl field
he is very very good he is i mean
really good if i'm a head coach i
wouldn't mind taking over that
because first of all you got a defense
you got some players
that is a really good personnel group
tom telesco does a great job at gm
they got talent you're really just
coming in with a chance to
go to the playoffs your first year i
love the chargers job
yeah i do too i'm with you on that
because i
i have my quarterback i do have some
star players
uh you know they haven't been healthy
but i do have star players i don't think
there's an
inordinate amount of pressure on you
with the chargers because
you're in los angeles so you can go
eight and eight
and people will go all right all right
we're starting to rebuild here you're
the you're the second team in
in that building and it just feels like
you could go in there and kind of ease
into that job you go into jacksonville
you get trevor lawrence
now all of a sudden all eyes are on you
like all right and if it's urban meyer
now you know people are going to expect
greatness out of urban meyer and trevor
lawrence
yeah and i think the urban meyer rumors
um which
let's be real i stoked a little bit with
my reports on saturday and sunday
are true he's they're interested he's
interested i would consider him the
front runner
they got to go through the process but
right now i would say there is a
legitimate chance of that happening that
is going to be
you know when when media is allowed to
do human things again like travel
everyone's going to be at their training
camp we're going to go live from their
camp it's going to be trevor lawrence or
justin fields
it's going to be sorry let me turn my
phone off it's going to be trevor
lawrence and justin fields
or justin fields and everyone's going to
be there and look
joe burrow was a great quarterback okay
he was a very promising rookie
i thought he did a great job they won
very few games it's hard
to have a rookie quarterback come in and
win a lot of games jags might be much
approved next year and go six and ten
that is a hard situation charges easier
and i know that the report is out there
that urban meyer
uh would be getting maybe 12 million
dollars a year
is that i i don't believe that's true
okay i mean he's gonna
he's gonna be richer than i am um
12 million is not accurate you know he
deserves a lot he's going to get a lot
but that number is
uh not relevant from what i understand
and then the jets situation
what do you do at number two and you
have sam darnold
uh how how uh how good
is that jet jets opening i'd say it's
pretty good
um you know there are some questions
though the roster needs a lot of help um
they are not talented at all and i think
for darnold
you know he he played well enough at the
end of the year that my gut is if they
want to trade him
they probably should do um you'll be
able to get a second rounder plus
or a late first rounder for sam darnold
that's fine
that's a very good investment early
first round started for three years
then you get a late one coming back then
you have
four first-round picks and they have
plenty
it's just historically they have not
been good
they need to fix the building still they
need to kind of come together a little
bit
i would say um and then there's the what
happens when woody johnson comes back
and honestly i don't have the answer to
that
that's that's a question is he in rap
report nfl network insider eric the
enemy going to have his choice of these
jobs
uh i hope he gets a job i think he's
deserving he's going to get
you know several interviews i know he's
already got some i think he actually
interviewed
yesterday lions maybe
i think he actually interviewed twice
yesterday he's a really good candidate
it is time i hope he gets a job
but the problem is you know these are
six jobs
let's let's assume for the sake of this
argument that urban meyer
ends up in jacksonville then that's five
jobs it just takes one owner to make the
independent decision that this is your
guy
the odds are still not with him just
because there's so many good candidates
so
i'm not convinced he gets one i just
know he's deserving and
honestly i kind of hope he does it's
just there's a lot of other really good
candidates too and that's a problem
he's older than mike tomlin
yeah i mean it's you know my my buddy
tom pelicero does a list of
sort of up-and-coming coaches and he
says all right if you're 40
you know if you're older than 40 you're
not on the list because you know like
i'm older than 40 i'm not up and coming
i'm just
old um you're old too by the way
um no offense um but eric the enemy
hasn't been on the list in
forever but people think he's still up
and coming like he's
he's been there but yeah it is time and
i start to look at these quarterbacking
situations
here and you know you start with the
jets what happens
we have this influx of first-round draft
picks potential first-round draft picks
but then i've got guys like matthew
stafford and matt ryan
jimmy garoppolo mitchell trubisky like
they're
this is these waves of quarterbacks
you know it keeps happening we always
say boy we haven't seen this in a long
time
here's another wave that's coming and we
thought the wave last year
was big and and lasting and it and it
probably will be but
what do you expect to happen with some
of the veteran quarterbacks
yeah last year was a weird anomaly i
thought because you had
brady and rivers and legit quarterbacks
changing teams
we're going to see more of that this
year so here's my early earlier read on
the situation okay
i have a hard time imagining that
stafford or matt ryan gets traded
because think about it the trades happen
in march that's when you get the value
that's when you
clear the salaries figure out what you
can use in free agency trades happen in
march
the lions and the falcons are not going
to know who their quarterbacks are in
march
they probably know in april when during
the draft but they're not going to know
in march so i don't think either of
those guys gets traded
now because you're not going to trade
him without knowing who the answer is
um is it possible garoppolo gets traded
i think it's possible
they came out and said yesterday that
they expect him to be back
i would say um we'll see
uh i would expect to move back unless
they get a better offer or a better
answer like
all of us um and then you know carson
wentz i think there's a real chance he
gets traded as well
indy would be a a really good option for
him but i mean we're going to see
a lot of movement and a lot of needs i
mean what are the saints going to do at
quarterback next year that's a big
question too i mean there's
it's going to be very interesting
off-season wait you don't think they're
sold
that that sean payton's not sold on
who's uh drew's replacement
i mean i i would just say and i don't
want to get an angry call from sean
payton
um my guess based on my eyeballs
and what i know is that they will
probably be looking for a quarterback
next year
to compliment jason who they also love
they love him
i know they love him but i'm not sure
he's a quarterback in the future there
he's not a starting quarterback
i mean i i just know when i talk to
defensive coordinators
head coaches general managers watching
taysom hill they were intrigued
but they were definitely not sold oh i'm
intrigued but i think jameis winston is
more of a
nfl quarterback and and hopefully he got
this you know hands-on tutorial
from sean payton and drew brees and
maybe that'll help his
judgment when he gets on the field let
me leave you with this have the dolphins
seen enough
of tua where they're they're convinced
they got the right guy
i think so um i have not heard otherwise
and but but i want to say this like
if you have an opportunity to get better
at quarterback as a team
you should take it it's your
responsibility to take it right so i
i cannot say i almost looking at the
quarterback situations across the lake
there's
only like 10 where you'd say they are
done right
like they're done they're not taken to
quarterback um
i would say for the dolphins i think
they are done
but i'm sure they're going to evaluate
all the quarterbacks in the draft i mean
tua is a rookie most rookie quarterbacks
don't play and if they do play they're
not good
they make mistakes they throw
interceptions they look bad they don't
get the offense
the problem with tua is we saw him play
um
so i think they are sold but i would not
necessarily bet my
life savings on good to visit with you
as always thanks for joining us i know
it's a busy time for you thank you ian
all right back to my phone take care man
that's ian rappaport nfl network insider
you can see him on nfl networks nfl game
day morning that'll be saturday and
sunday
at 9 a.m eastern